[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] a hot dog. He
[inaudible]. I got scared. Yeah.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] I said y'all be to say [inaudible].
Hi. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] well,
Dr. [inaudible] Papa makes me get a constant Clair that it wasn't that it done.
So it's joining of shade. It's cute. They've already had on there.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] the Homeland after today, huh?
Absolutely. Absolutely.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] so in pharmacy, you don't think that.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] Oh, shut that.
At
[inaudible] or GAM
[inaudible]. So I'd probably be more equipped or
[inaudible] as that.
Pops, the question.
That
[inaudible] [inaudible] thing was off or
[inaudible].
So the fun
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah.
And then you can just say in the answer that, so
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] also [inaudible] pharmacists to pharmacist.
[inaudible] say when John
[inaudible], uh
[inaudible] and there are some that had hot
[inaudible] E uh, or never do overs patina then,
uh [inaudible].
So.
So hard. You're hot.
[inaudible] [inaudible] call it. [inaudible] that? Can't say no,
now I'm coming to know first start Dawn.
Then I was going to clear me and then what live? Uh
[inaudible] unheard of glam.
Can you do
[inaudible] to stop, stay past staff?
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
I don't know if we [inaudible] tell them
[inaudible] yeah.
They call it [inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] or
[inaudible] but a sleuth board. I saw that in
[inaudible] or [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] also
[inaudible] [inaudible].
That's not any
[inaudible].
So [inaudible] till police
[inaudible] [inaudible] lymphoma Festa today.
[inaudible] so may I hate,
I hate the say to me I'm front to me and also
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] um,
[inaudible] uh, or, uh,
[inaudible].
Danville in Townsville. It's done. So you would have to be on for short yeah.
Down at, uh
[inaudible] for better. [inaudible] sorry.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
And I'm not sure
[inaudible] uh, or they truly are.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] man. Um,
[inaudible] [inaudible] so.
[Inaudible] or, or
[inaudible] uh
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah. We'll hammer. Uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] doc, uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
Well, then my daughter is in fresh to do better for all of it.
I, um,
I knew some of it by you. They come, they don't call the
[inaudible] and the
[inaudible] [inaudible] okay.
[inaudible] So your horse, your hammer.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] not an air [inaudible].
Geez. Okay. That's still some used to have all it that Hallowell that
[inaudible] inset [inaudible] Vivek did for me, for
[inaudible] or
[inaudible] yo Holly Smith.
[inaudible] they hurt and say I got a belt for
[inaudible] or your [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Of cows or also on
[inaudible] or [inaudible].
So she ended up [inaudible] on that second belt then
[inaudible] yeah, the whole
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Open up men library stuff.
As a new community. [inaudible] I saw the Gordon
[inaudible] [inaudible] Your [inaudible] and on.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. [inaudible] image.
[inaudible] STEM. If it's into
[inaudible] super less than Yvonne or sounds soy in my off day.
[inaudible] in the fortunate nuts that they come pull it
[inaudible] don't fall into
[inaudible] so
[inaudible] [inaudible] or here it was done. No,
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] the pellet. I was like, okay. It's at the Palmer loosening again.
[Inaudible].
Mr. [inaudible]. We live for chapter.
Well, Dickie
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] so he and I had Ms. Leave.
[inaudible] you? They opened up
[inaudible] [inaudible] or [inaudible] Destin, Oxo.
Half in that it sounded Watts. Some
[inaudible] as well, but here folks are on the river.
[inaudible].
Chris's metallic. So my Shana's some gift man to it.
[inaudible] out there at least I'm head of data and impair.
We'll go on that exam. The
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] and get on this. I'll be able to say
[inaudible] [inaudible] or the beauty of aminos. Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] men [inaudible] so
[inaudible] Mentor me take y'all
[inaudible] [inaudible] had us
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
Uh, or there's
[inaudible] or we'll do a lot of
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] Nice. [inaudible] capture, uh, the
[inaudible] [inaudible] sorry.
[Inaudible].